if you're a man just make sure the woman
you're having sex with won't kill your
child
that needs to be a question on Tinder
it is really screwed up because I've
given you a lot you know we've had a lot
of talk about don't sleep with somebody
you don't even fool around with a girl
if you're drunk or she's drunk because
you just never know if she's going to
turn on you and falsely accuse you of
something the next day or a thousand
other things one thing I haven't talked
to you about is and we have actually
talked about even if you got a girl
pregnant what I thought about that that
I said well even if she didn't want the
kid let's try to convince her to have it
and we'll raise it because it's your son
or daughter my grandchild and I really
believe that we should save that life
and and that's our family that baby but
I never ever once it did it occur to me
that you should have to have a
conversation with a girl would you have
a child if if you happen to get pregnant
and you know this woman brings up this
point and it just blows my mind and
these girls are so flip about it yeah
I'll kill your baby like oh my God yeah
it's definitely a tough thing to talk
about because like it's easier to say
now and then but in the moment it's like
holy [__] am I having a kid but then
like it's also like the guilt of having
an abortion would just be horrible too
you know what I mean yeah I probably
would would let the girl make the
decision like I wouldn't force her to do
anything but if I was a girl I probably
wouldn't get an abortion like you just
take self-accountability for stuff so
all free
stuff all right so now all right so I
could just like animate this
conversation it just keep going through
so not if they're Wanted Life begets
life I can't make a koala bear and no
matter how many times I have sex with my
husband you grab a limb you twist and
you pull
this is a regressive Antiquated view of
how we treat inconvenient human beings
you know it's sad like actually horrible
like when you're at like the train or
college campus and they have like the
pictures of the abortions and people are
like why are you showing that and it's I
mean that's how it is like that's what
it looks like that clump of cells that
horrible picture that you're seeing it's
like maybe some of you should see it you
know what I mean yeah I don't know I
mean even my service dog picture full of
[__]
what happens in an abortion so I'm so my
I must accept anxiety simple period she
just said exterminate
like a cockroach it's a human being full
of a hundred years of potential look at
this [__] guy well period question is
a tool that allows
right to pursue careers that is such a
misogynistic statement
yo hold this guy yeah I know we have a
video it's gonna be fantastic yes
yes so if your son was so pretty too
unfortunately you would want that girl
absolutely that's my grandchild and if
she didn't want to parent that child I
would say it's my responsibility I would
feel it's my responsibility to offer to
adopt that child
in the middle and got a 13 year old girl
practice you would want that girl to
have to go maybe you teach your third
like
13 when I'm 13 I was grinding Black Ops
zombies with the boys it does happen I
know a kid that I grew up with in the
neighborhood and when he was 13 He Got a
14 year old girl pregnant and they had
the child at 14. that is crazy yeah so
now when he was I would have a
six-year-old right now I mean imagine
being 13 years older than your kid when
you're 30 having a 17 year old that's
horrible that's I mean that's not
horrible that's crazy I would I would
say first of all no one wants a 13 year
old to be pregnant I think everyone so
she should get an opportunity
do you think that having an abortion
simply wipes it all away that gets that
gets rid of the sexual assault like
cures the pain she endures
that's not a consenting adult it's like
why do the Liberals always go to the
extremes with abortion like why are we
pretending like it's not just an
inconvenience thing 99 of the time like
if you had to take it all the abortions
and you had to go to like 13 year old
gets pregnant by another 13 year old
point zero zero zero one this this is
what we're arguing about right what if a
girl gets raped okay if a girl gets
raped yeah that's I mean that's funny
when you talk about rape they're like we
should women should be able to walk
through the park naked in the middle of
the night and uh then they'll say it
just teach your men not to rape well
just teach your little girls not to [__]
everything in sight I'm sorry I'm sorry
so should you if you're a minor should
you be able to have an abortion without
your parents consent yes
consent to anything and I said if you're
a minor can you consent to have an
abortion and you just said yes do you
understand how that's illogical
statement
you brought up a stupid point bimbo
I
agreement
whatever they should be able to have an
abortion as a 13 year old no one is
saying in the pro-life movement that a
woman a girl who is sexually assaulted
no one is saying that she should she
should become a parent we know it's
human because it has human parents
it's so funny because like if you go
like deeper down the rabbit hole aren't
abortion clinics like at such like
higher proportions in like black and um
people of whatever you get the numbers
there's like way more in like something
like a third or it's way more really
high number
um majority of uh black babies that are
aborted so don't tell me that black
lives matter and you want to kill you
know 100 well not even that you just go
like you keep going up the pyramid to
the top who's controlling it and you're
like
okay it's all the same people
controlling the narrative controlling
where the abortion clinics are what
people think about abortion not going to
go down there trying to keep my channel
no matter how many times I have sex with
my husband no matter what position I'm
having sex in I can only make a human
being and we know that human being is
alive because it's growing the cells are
rapidly multiply and what's really
fascinating is that human being is
self-directed it tells itself how it
developed Justice cells are alive but
that doesn't mean it is a light like it
doesn't have person does that make sense
does a baby have exactly the argument so
now when do you get personhood
when you can viably exist outside of the
womb without depending on the person
whose body you're in but see that's a
slippery slope because when when I ask
people when does personhood begin no
matter what college I'm at I always get
a different answer and throughout our
history when we separate being a human
being from being a person the results
are always catastrophe yes yes yes
that's what because think about slaves
they consider that they should be
subhuman
and that is by the same exact logic as
what these girls are saying about babies
no yeah it is pretty interesting and
different people the Jews aren't people
different definitions the person the
Nazi Germany all premature babies should
be left to die
you're watching
right so now all right so if I could
just like animate this conversation it
just keep going so not if they're wanted
your value as a human you matter
regardless of whether or not your
parents want you or regardless of how
other people see you you just checking
Instagram the pro-life movement is that
every single person no matter what you
say or what your beliefs are that you
have value and that you matter and it's
not your value doesn't stem from your
wantedness these guys somebody says that
you're one are you listening because
you're wanting this could change go
ahead tell me what she just said because
you're not your value isn't determined
about if someone else someone else
thinks of you right yeah did I miss it
did you did you get me did I get was I
wrong
because very very very close
I was focused on this guy look at him I
know they were all G's back there your
mother could want you one day than not
want you the other yeah I need to answer
her question because I think if you're
if I'm wrong about abortion and I if I
if I die I go to heaven and God's like
you've wasted your entire life it didn't
matter okay would you like me to answer
the question it didn't matter it doesn't
it doesn't matter at all Christian you
you wasted your time what have I done
with my life's work I've inconvenienced
women if you're wrong
you've left millions of people to die
because of because of their size
beliefs can't be right or wrong they
absolutely are theoretically police
beliefs can't be right or wrong
let's just keep going there is a right
wrong
is a regressive view this is called a
sofa clamp this is used in second
trimester DNA abortions when we know a
child can feel pain how do they end life
in a second trimester abortion I have
the quotes in my binder here from the
National Abortion federation's website
which is online you grab a limb you
twist and you pull
it this is a regressive Antiquated view
of how we treat inconvenient human
beings it is pretty sad that being
considered like pro-life is like extreme
because I don't I haven't even
considered myself like super pro-life
but it is like pretty horrible to think
about like I'm sure if anybody had to go
and sit in a room of a second trimester
abortion nobody would be on board after
that [__] like nobody yeah you know what
I mean
kill children in the third trimester
which is legal no I'm so we use this
this uh needle like similar in
aminocentesis
all right stop stop right there and then
that girl just said if you're getting an
abortion in the third trimester there's
most likely a medical reason or um you
know another serious reason like some of
the mother's in danger or something and
that is the that is the talking point
that is said all over the place on
college campuses and among uh Pro uh
Choice pro-abortion people and it is an
absolute fallacy it is simply not true
the NIH the National Institute of Health
which is uh you know a sister agency to
the uh CDC Center for Disease Control
here in the U.S uh did a study because
they wanted to know what the reasons
were for late term abortions and they
are almost identical to early term
abortions in the fact that 99 of them
are for the same reasons of
inconvenience and unwantedness that is a
fact an actual fact you can look it up
yourself do the homework don't take my
word for it and you've got these girls
running around going no they're only
doing that if the mother's life is in
danger no that's not true it's just not
true
abortionist uses ultrasounded guide
technology to identify the child in the
womb and they tried to get the digoxin
inserted as close to the heart as
possible to cause a cardiac arrest then
she walks around for two days with a
dead or dying child inside of her and
then she's given lemuria seaweed sticks
to ripen her uterus and she delivers a
dead child that this is a regressive
view this is a regressive view to
believe that this child must die in
order for you to live your life as you
see fit you have a very regressive you
I'm sorry to say
no
they all need to get vasectomies because
they're hopefully not having sex with
women that are going to kill the
children
would you get a vasectomy if you were a
man just make sure the woman you're
having sex with won't kill your child if
she conceives
that needs to be a question on Tinder
Jesse I'm out I would never touch any of
you either way
yes because that makes sure that makes
that justifies your experience who is
she talking to this guy why you hurt my
head on my man
you don't know if y'all are Boogie and
what would happen get out of here famous
police by insulting the way they look I
never said that that's literally what
you just said I will never touch any of
you anymore
I would never hang out with you because
you're pro-life and you love children oh
my God what worlds are we living in do
you want to try to make a call this is
the fall of the West be back I'm just
gonna be like current status
thank you
yes whiteboard listen if the pre-born
human being isn't a human being isn't
alive you don't need any justification
for abortion what's their vasectomy
argument anyways like would you get a
vasectomy so a lot of a lot of you know
a lot of the time they'll have you know
people because there's other
contraceptives you know extremists like
me
okay you don't you have choices to
prevent pregnancy so abortion doesn't
have to become your uh your go-to like
an IUD like uh birth control pills um
you know what the one thing they never
talk about is just like looking at your
calendar uh yeah that I mean that that
matters too but not everybody's regular
so there's that there's monitoring
um you know condoms and so women will go
well why do I have to do that why didn't
my boyfriend just get a vasectomy and my
answer to that because they think that
they're being so great like just put it
on the man it's his responsibility and
I'm like so now you're putting your
faith in in a man's hands you want to be
empowered you want to be the woman you
want to be strong and you don't want any
control you want to you want to put it
on him and again once again we're a
linguished control to the patriarchy it
is the stupidest it's just so asinine I
can't even find the words to describe
that so does that explain what that
argument is does that make sense yeah
just trying to be a feminist literally
don't give a [__] I don't care but if
the pre-born human being is a member of
our species and is alive the thing is
too like with sex like the girl is the
one that like gives it up in consents
like it's never like the dudes like all
right like every single scenario 99.9 of
the time it's like the guy getting the
girl to crack you know what I mean yeah
so wouldn't that mean that you're the
one that's responsible before it anyways
realistically I don't know if um follow
your logic but either way you want to be
you want to be have autonomy over your
own body you take control get the IUD
take the birth control pills make sure
that you be in control yeah but like my
point is like you're not just getting
pregnant magically like you're the one
that decides that like when you let him
make that chance yeah when you let a man
do that to you and if you even know that
there's no contraceptive happening in
the moment like [__] percentage rates
are skyrocketing there's no no
justification you get pregnant oh we can
get we can get that I we debated that
earlier but yes but there's no
justification that you can give to me
that would say it's okay to kill a human
being there's no justification but I'm
saying where you're going from there is
saying that it's morally wrong right
that's the that's what you're implying
is that's more I say it's morally wrong
to kill innocent humans and our laws
should reflect that and everyone views
pro-choice is going to challenge that by
saying yes because they don't want to
acknowledge the science because this is
this is the reality if you're a
pro-choice and I and I'm not attacking
anyone but if you're a pro-choice you
have to deny the humanity of the
pre-born child in order to justify the
belief that abortion is okay why because
changing your mind means that you may
have to reconsider some of the decisions
you've made in your life and that is
very hard that is why when I'm on the
campus I'm engaged in this discussion my
intent isn't to walk away with every
single Minds change because I know I'm
not going to be able to change a lot of
yours minds but my goal is to plant a
seed of Doubt to plan to see the truth
the later when you're reevaluating some
decisions you're making you may stop and
consider wait a minute it's so funny
because these girls are like but like my
career my career
I know I wish you would stop in the
middle like you keep stopping this dead
in the middle of sentences that that
she's making good all right all right
all right here let me just rewind it's
actually you're kind of wrecking the
flow with all due respect
damn the reader when you're reevaluating
some decisions you're making you may
stop and consider wait a minute that is
true and sometimes the truth is really
hard I was actually going to strengthen
your argument that would have been a
good time to stop and speak your mind
all right so now you want to cut it
again so here I'll go back again
because now it's suffering you will
adore determines whether or not you
should be killed that's a slippery slope
because well if someone's in a coma
can't feel anything they're not going to
feel any suffering can I kill them no
because we would say that's wrong call
me crazy by killing innocent people is
always wrong abortion is determining
that I can no longer have
a fetus in me because of my my own
circumstance what happens in an abortion
so I'm so my I must exterminate it
that's simple period that that's it
the fetus that's the best pro-life ad
I've ever seen
I must exterminate it that's a pretty
sad statement but if you want to talk
about statistics the latest Ohio
abortion to take that that was just
released last week black women and black
men make up 12 percent of the population
Ohio and they make up 40 percent of
abortions in Ohio that's statistics
that doesn't mean that you're allowing
them I'm saying you're allowing them you
want to say that's okay I love how the
white liberals like you said were so Pro
BLM are like yeah that's empowering that
we're killing half the black potential
population that's like that's great it's
unbelievable I I actually yeah I mean
it's just backwards I don't know I feel
like if that was you're so BLM then
you'd be like yeah and like abortion
shouldn't be for black people like we
need more of them we need more we need
all black people you think that would be
their Logistics together have more
babies no I don't know the world no I'm
just saying like with their logic that's
what I'm saying that should be the logic
have more babies take over the world
yeah
that 40 of women who seek abortions are
black when when black men women only
make up 12 or abortions that would make
a pursue a career they're they're taking
the operations my career to live their
lives
that's a
tools
statistics knock off a human life so
that I can have my control get bitched
at by my boss like yeah what I can go I
can go be a slave to Corporate America
you know I mean that that is not that is
a sick sick logic and the truth is women
are women you know all this
quote-unquote progress clearly they're
no happier with it clearly everyone
they're almost miserable no yeah they're
all depressed complained they're
depressed they're on they're on
antidepressants they drink they do drugs
it's the same point I said earlier like
any of these moms who are at one point
like when they were pregnant they were
like should I have it and you know raise
the kid or should I abort it and focus
on my career every single time they have
the kid they're like thank God I did
that that was so much better of a
decision than I can't been then becoming
a lot like oh my God like thank God I
got to sit in court yeah you're a lawyer
wow like congrats like that's that's
gonna really you know make us a ripple
in space-time rather than bringing a
life into Earth and the reality is you
can do both if you really still want a
career you can have a child I hear
Tristan's take on that he said to his
sister because she's a lawyer he's like
why wouldn't you just stay home and be a
fully good mother instead you chose to
be a half crappy lawyer and a half
crappy mother because your focus is on
the two things yeah so damn bro that's
not wrong I was having this conversation
with this girl once like late at night
at my cousin's house and you know we
were on um psychedelics and I was
talking to her and I was like she's like
super liberal and everything and I was
saying like as a woman you're not just
creating a life like you're literally
bringing in a Consciousness you know
what I mean like nobody like even the
car Iran says like the whole world
couldn't come together to make a fly
yeah you like as a person like you can
literally make a new conscious being and
we don't even like understand
Consciousness but you can create that
and then you're gonna sit here and say
like [__] that let me kill that let me
kill what would be a conscious being
over over a career like it's just crazy
talk it's a complete job I think it's
just a job on a job and who who am I
just tell people what I'm not I'm not
telling you what to do with your life
but I just feel like you know from all
the girls that I know they'd be a lot
happier focusing on the family that's
kind of the stuff that they like
intrinsically like to do even as little
girls like they they like like raising a
little daughter and then as you you get
more Matrix programmed they [__]
shove their ideas into you and you know
Force the way you think and you kind of
sway away from that and you go to the
liberal capitalist ideologies where
you're like oh maybe my career is more
important like no it's not it's nonsense
like let's just be straight up maybe a
girl on the right really made me sad
with the I'll just exterminate it yeah
it's simple I just gave you statistics
and you just acknowledged a pretty
racist statement and I'm letting you
make that in statement because I don't
need to say anything further to that she
said I was only bringing up race at
specific times you said I wasn't
bringing up statistics so I brought up
statistics and I brought breaks Bang
Bang
right to pursue
that is such a massage this dude's
really just trying to get some some
he's been that that's how he's gotten
some by learning these facts but good
for him the good these I excuse me I
call them facts not facts abortion it is
true abortion is a tool that allows a
woman to pursue her career because what
when you're pregnant all of a sudden
you're you're you're just a worthless
piece of [__] and you can't come into
society anymore is that what you're
saying it's such a misogynistic
statement that's what you just said it's
a tool that allows women to pursue
careers like I'm not capable of being a
mother without having an abortion that's
that's exactly what you just said in
fact that's what the Supreme Court said
and kcv Planned Parenthood and kcb
Planned Parenthood the Supreme Court
literally said women needed access to
abortion in order to achieve their
career goals and equal with men that
women have to have access to a special
surgery that dismembers another human
being in order to be equal to men I
fundamentally reject that because I can
gestate I can lactate I can menstruate
you can't do those things and I can
still beat your ass on any sat next
question
sorry you just got my feminists all that
this chick's hilarious like Avatar he
just got my feminist element I love this
lady Kristen Hawkins I just discovered
her I think she's Kick-Ass she's smart
and she stays so cool like I would be
those bodyguards would be there not to
protect me but protect to protect those
college girls from me because I would
lose my mind and have no patience at all
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe dislike if you
disliked the video follow me on
Instagram and um and I'll see you later
[Music]
spread the writing on the wall won't
last long yeah the feelings
[Music]